-You know, it's important
to remember
there are two sides
to every news story.
To make sure you get to see
important issues from all sides,
we've invited two of
our writers who have
very different points of view.
We will examine their opinions
in a segment we call
"Point, Counterpoint."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm joined by Ally and Amber.
Thank you so much for
being here today.
First topic...
it seems that every day that
someone within Trump's world
resigns or is fired.
Is this a sign of house
in chaos,
or that President Trump finally
seems to know
the kind of team he needs? Ally?
-You're giving him
too much credit.
All this turnover isn't
calculated.
It's the tantrums
of a man-child.
It's like if
a middle school bully
tried to run a PTA meeting.
Trump is nothing
but a big, fat baby.
-A big, fat baby? Amber?
-I love, big, fat babies.
[ Laughter ]
You see one, and you ask,
"How did you get so fat
if all you eat is milk,
little baby?"
But they don't answer because
they're a baby.
And when they're real fat,
you get to put your finger
on their chin and go...
[ Imitating Fat Albert ]
Hey, hey, hey, it's Fat Albert.
It's the cutest!
-You do have an excellent point.
Next topic...
Trump issued a memorandum
banning transgender people
from serving in the military
except under
limited circumstances.
Is this a dead end cause
or a win for his base? Ally?
-It's another sideshow.
I mean, think about it.
Right before
a national gun march
and a TV interview
with one of his mistresses,
Trump releases a hateful policy
to grab headlines.
The courts will hopefully
fight this,
but I think it's another one of
Trump's distracting stunts.
-Distracting stunts. Amber?
-I love stunts.
[ Laughter ]
You'll be watching a movie,
and then the music will start
to get tense, like...
[ Hums tense theme ]
And then the actors
will punch each other
and break everything
and fly through walls,
and then at some point,
you'll be, like, "Wait,
that's not the actor.
That's a stuntman."
Then the actor reappears
and says a cool line like...
[ Deep voice ]
"I thought I might as well
take a stab at it."
[ Normal voice ] And you're
like, that's cool because
he stabbed him.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, what she's saying
is completely off-topic.
-Ally, it's called
"Point, Counterpoint."
You make a point.
She makes a counterpoint.
-The Pope was wrong.
Hell is real.
[ Laughter ]
-Ally.
-Ally, don't be sad.
Put a grin on your chin,
open your arms,
and bring it in!
-Absolutely not. Next topic.
-Finally, after Joe Biden
said in his speech he would
have beat Trump up
in high school,
Trump tweeted
that if they did fight,
Biden would have gone down
hard and fast,
while crying ahead
of the midterms.
Is this the sort of leadership
we need from either party? Ally.
-It's like
we've completely forgotten
how a leader
is supposed to act.
This country has gone insane.
I've lost all hope.
-I know what would make
you feel better.
-I'm not giving you a hug.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Well, then how
about a big stunt sequence?
-You mean it?
-Yeah. Go nuts.
[ Action movie music playing ]
Aah! Uhh!
-[ Whimpers ] Uhh!
Aah! Oh!
♪♪
-[ Grunting ]
[ Glass shatters ]
[ Grunting ]
♪♪
-[ Audience groans ]
-Hey, you, two, knock it off!
-Take a closer look at this,
bitch!
-Uhh! Oh, no!
-Aah!
-Say it!
-No!
-Okay, fine.
Give me a hug.
-Okay.
[ Applause ]
-This has been "Point...
[ Groans ] Counterpoint."